[Music]
you know I just really need to get my
feelings out and things have just been
so weird between us and I've been on
tour and I've been busy and I know
things get lost in translation and I
don't mean to neglect you I really don't
and I just really need you to know that
I love you always
yeah I'm rich Brian and I'm Joe G last
summer we became master chefs at the ad
a rising summer mansion and this year
we're teaming up with even more chefs
and special guests and asking a few of
our 80 a rising labelmates to help us
out
welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion what's up you guys it's your
girl Nikki welcome back to the peace
mansion so the boys are out today
[Music]
so I'm taking over today you know
hashtag GRL PWR I don't if you can like
edit that in by like girl power um so
yeah I'm taking over taking charge on
some Cooking Mama [ __ ] so I've been
touring a lot and I've been on the road
and sometimes you just want that little
piece of home and I am currently feeling
super homesick so today we're gonna be
making one of my favorite comfort foods
from back home we're talking about
Indomie this baby right here we're gonna
welcome my friend Inga from BuzzFeed and
she's gonna help me make all of this
into some crazy [ __ ]
so Inga indomie I'm excited to create a
lot of crazy things with you today but
obviously you are the indomie expert so
it's gonna be a collaboration all right
cool I'm down let's do this
suck down a couple videos with instant
ramen yeah every time we do a video like
that all the comments are about to know
me like I'm not even chewing every but
there's like it's just such a huge fan
base right like how big of a deal is it
for you back home it's the ultimate
comfort food cuz like you eat Indomie
when you're like 45 percent hungry so
it's not really like a meal it's more of
a snack yeah it's like 12 a.m. you're
drunk as hell that sounds about right
yeah you going home you're like where
the [ __ ] is my endo me it's just
whenever I think of endo me I just think
of sitting in front of TV with my family
bullshitting talking about [ __ ] and
stuff you know as we all do and yeah
it's just it's the ultimate comfort food
okay so we have quite the selection the
assortment here we have all these
different flavors but I'm feeling like
doing something classic today so let's
just go with your bog-standard me going
me say that again
me going Miko right exactly
yeah nice yeah okay you're ours with it
it literally translates to fried noodles
you don't use scissors we're gonna go
crazy you got a rule you don't use
scissor I mean it's just like that's
what we needed and don't say okay you're
just very primal its abyss world just
like you know the water's boiling now so
we're gonna just dump this guy in mm-hmm
each pack comes with these babies
Indomie is not anomia without these guys
whoever the [ __ ] came up with these I
don't know why you're not the most
celebrated man on this earth or a woman
Wow huh or woman
I don't know right after he's a girl
cowards exactly I know I should just say
Scorpius
[Music]
how do you usually cook your noodles for
I eyeballin expect you that is the
classic way to do it it's just an
intrinsic feeling that comes with being
Indonesia and you know it's just like in
your DNA or just like oh those are done
you know I still never know how they're
done
I I guess you can't because they're not
Indonesia all right all right
the noodles are cooked it's like kind of
all dente I like it kinda bra correct
kind of oh not wrong but like you know
I'm saying just like yeah poppy um all
right so we're gonna grab these guys cuz
this is hot I'm gonna drain ahead we're
gonna drain this yeah it's a very
scrambling process you can't like
elegantly make indomie we're gonna turn
the pot back on and then we're gonna
crack a couple of eggs
I usually go for two eggs my dad thinks
I'm crazy for doing so I mean get your
protein in right No Fax Oh see that yes
this is the final product
yeah this looks like comfort food it
does right this is how I eat it at home
please chef
taste taste man I'm gonna taste it how
do you know it's gonna come areas low
key
do you like it yeah you build the
noodles just right though it's the
perfectly you you're saying just the
right but it's a feeling yeah I told me
it's like an intrinsic yes yes sir all
feeling hmm taste of home yeah you feel
like you're on a plane pointing back
home right now well I'll call my dad
right now I miss him this is great
Ramez its own I literally eat it
straight out a packet but now you know
the wheels are kind of turning and I'm
just like what else what else could we
make within domain there are a lot of
things we can do within domain and this
might actually blow your mind but you
know I work a lot with desserts in my
videos oh so I'm a turn I'm actually
gonna try putting into me a homicide of
chocolate and I know that's it was a
kind of creamy egg you know how you get
like crunchy chocolate sometimes that's
what we're gonna oh like the crunch bars
yes like Nestle Crunch yes
crunch challenge
activated let's go
all right so we've got the chocolate
melting over here we have the Indomie we
have corn flakes dried fruit and candy
melts okay you ready I'm very ready you
look like you're nervous I mean I'm
ready to be blown away so you want to
start crushing the noodles oh my god and
that's fun okay now we're gonna pour the
corn flakes
so now just like go in with your hands
and crush it again
yes like massaging it you know this is
fun relieves stress and fear stress wow
this is really therapeutic I feel like I
could just own up this into a podcast
for you close your eyes take a deep
breath listen to the sounds of the ocean
you are worthy of love feel the indomie
between your fingers all right cool eyes
own doubt for a second this is so fun
[Music]
so you see how you want to do like a
little like you know that looks so good
yeah it looks so good it looks
inappropriate okay so I'm gonna start
pouring this in we're just gonna combine
these two together so like how do you
come up with all of these crazy recipes
a lot of times it's just like me
going on the internet I see something
cool or like I see Instagram then I'm
like oh what's that and then I sort of
do my own spin on it you know they say
not to play with your food but sometimes
cool stuff can come out of playing with
your food a little bit
[Music]
so this is the part where you go crazy
this is art yeah we can go abstract on
this um Jackson Pollock action I'm just
putting some dried food on mine so like
dried Kiwi banana this is not even a
competition at this point not a
competition I mean it never was to begin
with but if it ever if it was like it's
now not anymore so we're gonna put this
in the fridge now and pop them out later
okay while we wait I got another little
something for you okay great we're
excited
all right yeah
alright Inka so what do we have here
what are we making you know we've seen
ramen burgers yes the internet I also
made it for one of my videos but it like
blew up so I was thinking why not try to
do that with our favorite indomie
there's a little circle mold this is
what will give it that circular shape
right and this is important we just cook
this into me it has to be hot there's no
egg or anything in there yep it kind of
just glues together because of the
starch ok just fold it up like that ok
that's your first ramen bun ok so now
we're gonna put these buns in the fridge
let it chill for two hours but what are
we gonna do for two hours
I don't know well come up with something
fun
[Music]
ed wanna movie magic Tara that's amazing
okay and you see when you open that ah
boom what
that's your ramen bun what's gonna
sizzle yeah we just want it to have some
sort of code and brownness and then also
I was thinking you know that like sweet
soy sauce and chili we were talking
about yeah we're gonna actually use this
to make like a sauce so I'm gonna put
this here these are done they're lightly
toasted okay so now we cook the beef
patty so this is just pure beef your
beef just watching this cook I know I
feel like we're proud parents right now
yeah awesome
[Music]
look at that that's a beauty right there
ass under me
transform
[Music]
that means it's really good dude that's
[ __ ] delicious
all right so burgers great mm-hmm we
still got dessert coming up remember
those chocolate bars hopefully they've
set by now all right you ready let's
let's go try so ready let's go all right
[Music]
okay whoa this is what it looks like Oh
yours looks beautiful yes okay a bit
clunky but your here's the tricky part
getting them out what about did this
yo do that
dude this shit's artisanal like I'd go
to like good divert or some [ __ ] and get
this you know okay so now teach me your
ways how did you and literally you just
map it was like boom like oh I don't
know if the mines gonna work
[Music]
alright so clearly mine was not a
success but it's okay so I'm gonna try
because this still looks delicious
you got it look Ronnie bail oh yeah
and the corn flake alright cheers Cheers
[Music]
No
is it crunch me that is [ __ ]
delicious mm-hmm Wow
so you did a bunch of stuff today we
start about the class ii know me we did
the chocolate bars and we did the ramen
burger which one is your favorite I'm
not really making any sounds but I'm
gonna go with the burger really that
really savory that was crazy
thousand words Wow but you learn a lot
of new things and I can now you know I
really there's anything we can do I
truly did endo me it's just like
suddenly three-dimensional you know I'm
like you meet somebody and they're like
super like 2d and they're just like one
person right then like you get to know
them and they're like all these
different sides and that's how I feel
about him Doby right now
never thought I'd know me could be
elevated this way but in go right here
changed my mind
all right you guys thank you so much for
joining us
Inga thank you for helping me out today
thank you for having me this was peace
mansion we're out peace peace
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update our first ever
collaborative sauce it's here 88 rising
first we feast joining forces to make
dragon in the clouds
you saw me Joe G and rich Brian mixing
it up in the cauldron yuzu from Japan
etc I'm peppercorn from China and of
course you know your boy brought the
heat but don't worry we got some
professionals together to make sure this
stuff is FDA approved extremely limited
very quality and something what we're
super proud of if you want to get your
hands on dragon in the clouds visit 88
night market calm that's 88 night market
calm don't miss your chance the dragon
you can fly away
[Music]